en cali los jóvenes de portada al mar
vuelven a bloquear su punto lo
interrumpieron cuando se enteraron de
que había personas cerca tratando de
hacer un peaje ilegal no quieren que les
relacionen pero algunos coches hacen el
gesto de pagar ellos no aceptan es la
primera línea esto surgió de manera
espontánea y que los muchachos
literalmente están saliendo a
enfrentarse a la policía con palos y
rocas cuando ellos tienen gases tienen
pistolas sin en tanquetas entonces a
surgió como una conciencia de que la
organización popular puede ganarle a
cualquier forma organización estatal
jefferson se encarga de mediar con
distintos actores y comprobar que se
respetan los derechos humanos portada al
mar es el único punto sin muertos han
dialogado con la fuerza pública y con
los vecinos en un sector donde en pocas
calles se pasa de lujosos edificios a
una humilde ladera la composición del
grupo va de estudiantes politizados
hasta jóvenes que viven del día a día
estos son sus reclamos
de igualdad en todo estudiantil y
laboral en cuanto a salud de una buena
salud qué
y podamos avanzar la primera línea ha
evolucionado ahora en el ancla a la
cancha del barrio están organizados
realizan asambleas y actividades
culturales tienen misión médica donde
acuden vecinos del barrio también tienen
una olla comunitaria la lideran las
madres de los jóvenes les llegan
donaciones de los vecinos de la ladera y
están orgullosas uno los admira los
admira por esa gallardía los admira por
esa por esa fuerza que le ponen a sus
cosas antes de las ollas comunitarias
muchos chicos no tenían ni para una
comida diaria una violencia que estalló
en el paro nacional que les ha obligado
a taparse el rostro para por fin ser
vistos